[Musique]
songez vous présenter c'est un garçon
que j'ai connu à montréal
c'est un grand canadien saleh alors il
m'a dit est ce que vous pourriez jazz et
moi monsieur ce pad ça se dit comme ça
jase et ça veut dire est ce que vous
pourriez parler moi monsieur spad je lui
dis je vais lui en parler et vous allez
longtemps c'est un garçon charmant qu'à
une poésie est tout à fait ravissante
il est grand il est charmant parce que
si je pouvais abuser un peu encore de
vos instants je pourrais vous parler de
la genèse de ce garçon voilà il
s'appelle après pour l'évêque
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà un jour comme ça chez mon
père c'est mon père qui m'a dit pourquoi
tu veux qu'on ferme ce voyage en france
la france le pays de nos ancêtres
le berceau de notre langue de notre foi
moi l'idée me souriait mais c'est ma
mère qui était pas d'accord parce que je
n'en connais que deux jeux mais à paris
puis qui avait rapporté un programme de
folies bergère ça fait qu'à 10 comme un
turc ne pas envoyer notre garçon l'a pas
pour aller voir des danseuses
comment qu'il dit mon père des danseuses
sinon on va pouvoir des danseuses et des
jeunes envoient s'instruire ans dit
avoir visité le musée du louvre une tite
a pas besoin tentèrent la seule dans ce
cas là dedans c'est la vénus de milo 1
est en marbre puis a pas de grands
arguments irréfutables
la preuve la main j'étais sur le bateau
son jumeau tampon je m'entends pas trop
vous en parler c'est un bateau en clair
le bar permet à 9 heures puis tous les
jours on mangeait le même poisson avec
des noms différents
enfin un atteint les côtes de france
le chaton un jeu parce que sous le règne
du roi soleil
le ministre a déjà déclaré faut défendre
le château avant les écuries les écuries
c'est à nous autres
je n'insiste pas en débarquant ravin
garçons partent mais banal jusqu'au
train j'arrive pour me donner un
pourboire
mais comme j'étais pas très familiers
avec la monnaie du pays
je me suis dit je m'en vais lui donner
la plus grosse pièce comme ça il y aura
pas d'erreur mais ici en france la plus
grosse pièce de 5 francs
mais quand vous le savez pas ça fait
c'est là que j'ai appris tête de lard
animal provincial moulin de mal embouché
enfin tout un répertoire classique à mes
remarques et moi ça m'a pas trop surpris
pas j'avais déjà lu les carnages major
thompson à l'arrivée à paris j'ai dit au
chauffeur au louvre s'il vous plaît
belle boutique je suis resté surpris pas
acheter la première fois que je voyais
un musée où l'on vendait des cravates
depuis des bretelles me suis dit ça y
est ça y aller les américains n'ont pas
voulu leur prêter d'argent pour
apprendre le musée le par la suite ont
par la suite j'ai su qu'il y avait qu il
y avait le louvre le musée
le magasin puis le louvre le musée
d'ailleurs j'ai mieux compris en
visitant parce que tout à coup je me
suis retrouvé au pied d'un escalier bien
où tu t'es ce khadija perçu comme
l'espèce est en jeu pas de tête
kamel ra à respirer l'air frais sur le
devant des bateaux
j'ai demandé au gardien que ce sens ce
faisant je pète et mathieu mais c'est la
victoire de samothrace ah oui mais moi
j'ai ici pas de tête comme ça il m'a
polaire demain victorieux mais après je
me suis rappelé la révolution française
et la guillotine agediss et ça c'est
bien français mais c'est une victoire
poursuivant la visite me suis rendu
place de la concorde pouvoir l'obélisque
ne marcherait pas ce texte oblige
croyait que telle espèce de cathédrale
alors arrivée place de la concorde
départ mais un agent par une entrée à
l'obélisque
il m'a répondu vous pouvez toujours
essayer
ben pas par la suite j'ai super
obélisque d'un monument funéraire élevé
à la gloire des roises égyptien et sur
laquelle on racontent leurs exploits
je me suis rappelé le roi farouk je me
disais que je n'insiste pas à tous mais
qu'est-ce que j'aperçois l'autre bout
des champs-elysées l'arc de triomphe
combien de vraiment ça m'a fait quelque
chose parce que j'avais vu souvent quand
on grapille dans les journaux fait j'ai
dit au chauffeur
après deux triangles s'il vous plaît et
par le magasin on arrive à l'arc de
triomphe quand tous les gens qui aiment
j'aurais voulu aller voir de plus près
j'aurais voulu aller toucher impossible
je sais pas si vous avez déjà remarqué
mais dans les journaux les gens qu'on
voit photographie au pied de l'arc de
triomphe ce sauveur j'entends des
militaires cancon et après décorés
pourquoi est ce que vous pensez qu'on
les décors sénile terme or c'est
justement parce qu'ils ont réussi à
traverser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]